Brett Kavanaugh is accuser demands
special treatment from the Senate
Judiciary Committee Republicans tried
out a bizarre defense and president
Trump responds I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so much to get to and I'd like to remind
you right now I'll remind you again at
the end of the show because that's what
I do that this Sunday is the premiere of
the Ben Shapiro election special on Fox
News so that'll be really cool that's 8
p.m. on Sunday so make sure to check
that out also ensure that you're
protected against the causes of
inflation okay there could be higher
wages because the increase in minimum
wages across the country actually
increases prices importing imports are
going to increase prices as well raw
materials prices are increasing the
tariffs rising housing prices just look
at the markets and the government
solutions recessions is printing more
money and this is why you might want to
protect some of your assets against
inflation that could be headed our way
with precious metals gold is a safe
haven against uncertainty my savings
plan is diversified and yours should be
as well as we take all your money and
take it out of the stock market and put
it in gold that doesn't mean take some
of your money and put it in precious
metals the company I trust with precious
metal purchases is Birch gold group and
right now thanks to a little-known IRS
tax law you can even move your IRA or
eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver which is
perfect for folks who want to protect
their hard-earned retirement savings
from future geopolitical uncertainty
when you look back historically you'll
see when the bottom falls out of
everything else Gold actually safeguards
your savings Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau you know
all about Birch Gold's free information
kit but for a limited time qualified
purchases can earn up to an additional
10 grynn and precious metals for free
through September 30th to find out if
your purchase qualifies contact Birch
gold right now go to birchgold.com slash
man talk to a bird schools
representative mention that I sent you
that's birchgold.com /ban this offer
only runs until September 30th terms and
limitations apply so go ask your sales
representative for details right now
birchgold.com slash been all righty so
the latest in the Brett Kavanaugh
hearing saga is more stupid so one of
the things that's been deeply irritating
about this entire saga is that truth and
innocence guilt none of these things
matter anymore truth doesn't matter and
guilt doesn't matter innocence doesn't
matter all that matters is the political
Machiavellian manipulations of Democrats
and it turns out of the accusers lawyer
so Christine Blasi Ford is the person
who is now accusing Brett Kavanaugh of
sexual assault 36 years ago at an
unspecified time and
specified place and she originally said
I'd like to come and talk to Republicans
and Republicans said sure let's do it
and then she said well no I don't want
to do that
I said well but you just said you wanted
to do it just like no no no I don't want
to do it anymore and I want the FBI to
investigate and Republicans said well
the FBI doesn't investigate state crimes
36 years ago you know when the FBI did a
did an investigation of the sexual
harassment allegations against Clarence
Thomas in 1991 they did that because
Clarence Thomas was an employee of the
federal government on federal property
under federal jurisdiction at the time
that those accusations were about the
same is not true in a private home in
the middle of Maryland in 1982 like
that's not an actual that's not an
actual thing the FBI does and so
Republicans were like well we're not
gonna tell the FBI to go investigate a
state crime that happened 36 years ago
on the basis of no actual evidence
except for an allegation that can't even
name time in place and so why don't you
just come and talk about it now
Cavanaugh has been very clear about this
Cavanaugh put out a letter he said I
want to be heard I'm perfectly happy to
come before the committee he said I want
to continue to want a hearing as soon as
possible so I can clear my name since
the moment I first since the moment I
first heard this allegation
I have categorically and unequivocally
denied it I remain committed to
defending my integrity he says he's
gonna be there on Monday he's going to
testify under oath
that's more than Ford is willing to do
he says he's going to put himself under
penalty of perjury
that's more than Ford is willing to do
and I'm sorry a polygraph is not the
same thing as coming and testifying
under oath because if you testify
falsely under oath you could go to jail
if you're held to account for perjury
so Cavanaugh is saying I'm willing to
sit there and categorically deny
anything like this ever happened and I'm
gonna do that under oath and meanwhile
Ford's lawyers are attempting
desperately to avoid her actually
testifying so she's issued a list of
demands now I don't know since when it's
become a thing to issue a list of
demands to testify in front of the
Senate Judiciary Committee the Senate
Judiciary Committee does indeed have
subpoena power I looked it up this
morning so there is a power of subpoena
for the Senate Judiciary Committee the
committee rules allow subpoena under two
circumstances this is section nine of
the rules for the Committee on the
judiciary the chairman of the committee
with the agreement of the
so that'd be Diane Feinstein or by a
vote of the committee may subpoena the
attendance of a witness at a committee
or subcommittee hearing or committee
deposition or the production of
memoranda documents records or any other
materials any such subpoena shall be
issued upon the signature of the
chairman or any other member of the
committee designated by the chairman so
in other words all Republicans really
have to do here is subpoena her they
could theoretically just vote on
straight party lines to subpoena
Christine Blasi for it and then she'd
have to testify but they're not doing
that instead because they are trying to
be solicitous of her emotional needs
they are they're being very I think open
about all of the things that they are
willing to do for her what are some of
her demands well frankly her demands are
totally crazy
okay the demands that she's making are
nuts so here are some of the things that
she is now demanding no outside counsel
questions her so she refuses to allow
Cavanaugh's lawyer to question her in
any hearing instead she wants it just to
be the Senators the reason for that is
so the Democrats can run out the clock
and grandstand every just turns into the
Senators questioning her then it's
certainly not gonna be out truth or
about falsity it's just going to be
about Dianne Feinstein and Kamala Harris
signaling for 20/20 I was gonna be Cory
Booker signaling for 20/20 you say that
this man raped you and these evil white
Republican all been here who want to
question you they're evil white and
they're Republican old men that'll be
Cory Booker it's gonna be his second
spartacus moment woo that's what
Christine blazing Ford's lawyers one
that if she's there she can be defended
by Democratic senators and then the
people who will be asking her questions
from the right there'll be people like
Orrin Hatch who was born during the
during the James K Polk administration
like that's that's what she's actually
looking for okay so that is demand
number one that is an idiotic to man
that has nothing to do with reality
second this one is truly insane she is
demanding that the defense should
testify first that's crazy
there is no proceeding in American life
where the defense to a charge testifies
first for a good reason you don't know
what you're being charged with if I were
to go into court and the police said you
know what we've got a charge against you
the charge is manslaughter I was like
well I need to hear the details of that
so I can you know defend myself you know
maybe give you an alibi tell you where I
was
the time they say you know what no we're
not gonna give you any of that stuff you
need to present your defense first you
would rightly say what are you talking
about how am I supposed to defend myself
against charges when the only thing we
know is that you claim it that in a
house at a time in a place I did
something wrong
how the hell am I supposed to even
mobilize hit the fence
based on that there's no way to do that
so she's demanding that as well
she is also demanding a subpoena against
mark judge now that one I find the least
objectionable that they should subpoena
mark judge mark judge is supposedly a
witness to what happened asking him
questions under oath seems to me fairly
reasonable but they should also subpoena
all the other people who she says were
there they should subpoena everybody if
they're going to do like a full criminal
trial here or alternatively she should
testify and Cavanaugh should testify she
also says that Cavanaugh cannot ask her
questions and Cavanaugh cannot be in the
same room as her and this is so
anti-constitutional the Constitution
says that you have a right to confront
your accuser but if somebody accuses you
of a crime you have a right to actually
question the witness you have a right to
confront it let's be real about this
this has become a criminal trial of
Brett Kavanaugh this is a criminal trial
Brett Cavanaugh's career either will end
with him on the Supreme Court or will
end with him bankrupt right it will end
with him maybe really losing his job on
the DC Circuit Court of Appeals being
destroyed as a human being that's where
this goes if people feel that lazy Ford
is telling the truth so to treat this as
anything less than what it is which is
essentially a criminal trial is really
absurd but this is what Ford is pushing
and she's saying that if you don't
fulfill those commitments then I'm not
gonna come testify at all we still don't
know whether she's gonna come and
testify next Thursday they're probably
trying to push this beyond next thursday
because if Kavanaugh is confirmed after
the end of September then he can't sit
during a full term of the court so maybe
that is what they're maybe that's what
they're looking for but this is all this
is all ridiculous ridiculous stuff also
you can tell how politicized all of this
is so how politicized is all of this at
this point how much of this is
Democratic manipulation virtually all of
it is Democratic manipulation how do we
know that well there's a story out today
the Cavanaugh's accuser it now has a new
adviser who is this advisor Ricky
Seidman now you may not remember that
riki Seidman Ricki Seidman is the person
who is working for the Senate Judiciary
Committee for Senator Ted Kennedy all
the way back during the Anita Hill
hearings hey Ricki Seidman is the person
who went and solicited a Nita Hill in
the first place to come forward
with her very questionable sexual
harassment stories about Clarence Thomas
and now this accuser has hired the same
person to advise her through this
process does that sound partisan to you
imagine that I came forward with a bunch
of allegations against Barack Obama
about something and the person I hired
to guide me through that process was Ken
Starr would people think maybe that that
was a partisan thing because this sounds
kind of partisan Seidman said in a brief
interview I believe her and I think
she's very courageous for coming this
far she worked as Joe Biden's
communications director during the 2008
general election campaign and in 2009
she helped the White House managed the
confirmation of Sonia Sotomayor so this
woman who only cares about getting to
the truth not about the politics she
only cares about justice and getting to
the truth just hired a political hack
responsible for the raising of Annie to
hell the Joe Biden campaign in 2008 and
Sonia Sotomayor now again for the for
the one millionth time maybe Ford is
telling the truth it's possible she is
it's possible she's misremembering as
possible she's telling the truth if
she's telling the truth we have to get
to the seriousness of the allegations
the truth or falsehood of the
allegations we must get to that if we do
not get to that all of this is worthless
and that's the part that's so irritating
I want to know whether it's true or
false because if it's true it's damning
obviously if it's true that Brett
Kavanaugh when he was 17 years old
pushed a girl into a room puts her down
on a bed lay on top of her tried to rip
off her clothes put his hand over her
mouth to prevent her from screaming I
don't think you should sit on the
Supreme Court you know there's some
people on the right side and say well if
that happened I don't see why that
should Mar him the rest of his life no I
think that that probably should Mar him
that's that that's a really really bad
crime again if the the reason I know
it's a bad crime because if somebody did
that to my sister and I came in in the
middle of that event I'd shoot him right
I literally I would take I would pick up
a blunt instrument and beat the living
bejesus out of them right so it's a bad
thing to do anything bad enough
that yes it should haunt you if that's
something that you did but we have to
know whether it's true or false it's
because I take the charges seriously
that I want to know if they're true or
false if I didn't take the charges
seriously I wouldn't care whether they
were true or false if she came forward
and she accused Brett Kavanaugh of
drinking of shoplifting a Slurpee in
1982 then I wouldn't care I'd be like
okay fine he shoplifted a Slurpee in
1982 is a stupid kid who cares but this
is a serious charge which requires
serious evidence and a serious hearing
which is not what we're getting and the
Democrats obviously are not interested
in getting down to the bottom of this
they're interested in the politicking
surrounding all of it and I'm going to
explain more how obvious that is in just
one second but first let's talk about
your bathroom habits no matter what you
do in the bathroom to get ready every
morning Dollar Shave Club has everything
you need to look feel smell your best
they've amazing shower stuff hair
styling products toothbrushes and
toothpaste and of course the razors and
shaved supplies I love their amber
lavender body cleanser it is delightful
they also have like a sage and black
pepper shampoo that smells really good
and I'm big into the into the good
smelling body washes and shampoos
because I do want to smell like a
delight
I may be a hard-and-fast political
pundit but I am also a man who likes to
smell decent and that's where Dollar
Shave Club comes in that that's how I
get ready in the mornings but that may
not not be the way that you get ready in
the mornings maybe you shave your whole
body to get ready for a bike race
because you're some sort of weirdo
Dollar Shave club's executive razor and
shea butter can help you might do your
hair to get ready for your soccer match
because you're European or something
Bogey's by DSC can help you get your
style right the thing is no matter what
you do to get ready DSC has everything
you need and right now you can get ready
with an amazing deal on any of their
starter sets I recommend the daily
essential starter set because I love
that amber lavender body cleanser go
over to Dollar Shave Club calm slash Ben
pick your own DSE starter set for just 5
bucks after your starter set products
ship at regular price that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben again
dollarshaveclub.com
slash Ben go check them out right now
dollarshaveclub.com slash man for that
special deal all right so how do we know
how political the Democrats are making
this here's how political the Democrats
are making this Elizabeth Warren a
fighter on behalf of women everywhere me
too Elizabeth Warren right Elizabeth
Warren sent out a fundraising letter on
the basis of these accusations she put
out a fundraising email blast quote this
is how
Brett Kavanaugh is already disqualified
to serve on the Supreme Court but now
we're learning new information about a
sexual assault allegation if we get if
we all get in this fight right now from
Boston and across the country
then we've got a fighting chance at
stopping the Republicans and Cavanaugh
in their tracks and then there's a big
donate Now button so she's using a
sexual assault allegation to fundraise
for herself really classy not political
at all not political in the slightest
just about getting to the truth just
about defending the rights of women not
political at all not political in any
way and and the way that the Democrats
are trotting all of this happening this
really is McCarthyism it's McCarthyism
of the highest order so Kirsten
Gillibrand who as I said yesterday is a
complete weather vane of a human being
all she does is look at which way the
prevailing winds are blowing and then
she turns in that direction so she said
why isn't Brett Kavanaugh asking for an
FBI probe is that she said maybe he's
not asking for an FBI probe because he
thinks he's innocent yeah I accuse
kirsten gillibrand of slaughtering
monkeys in her backyard that's what I
accused her of why doesn't she demand an
FBI probe to clear herself of the animal
abuse why kirsten gillibrand talk you're
stupid who is not asking the FBI to
investigate these claims the White House
dr. Cavanaugh excuse me judge Kavanagh
has not asked to have the FBI review
these claims is that the is that the
reaction of an innocent person okay let
me also point something out about this
FBI nonsense Clarence Thomas there was
an FBI investigation into the claims by
Anita Hill you noted found that FBI
investigation they found nothing
it found nothing and found no outside
verification of any of the charges did
that stop the Democrats from smearing
Clarence Thomas of course not did it
stop the left from believing Tarrant
Clarence Thomas is a serial sexual
abuser even though there were no
corroborated right there are no other
women who came forward and said that
Justice Thomas ever did anything like
that and he denied that info of course
not so all this focus on the FBI stuff
is clearly misdirection because if the
FBI report comes out and says hey we've
got no evidence the Democrats will just
say well the FBI is dominated by Trump
who cares it's it's absolutely
ridiculous and that's not all
kirsten gillibrand had to say kirsten
gillibrand then came for and she said
listen we shouldn't even have a hearing
she should skip the here
so the same people saying Republicans
refused to hear her story they refused
to hear her story senator Kirsten
Gillibrand says she shouldn't even tell
our story because Republicans are gonna
refuse to hear it now there's nothing
more irritating in life than a person
who keeps changing their mind about what
exactly they want from you if my wife
says you know honey I want to talk about
something say okay let's talk about it
you know what I don't want to talk about
it anymore just because you said that I
don't want to talk about anyone but you
wanted to talk about it but now I don't
want to talk about it and I need you to
stop bothering me about it I would
rightly say what crazy pills are you on
today my wife has never said anything
like that because she's not a crazy
person but Kirsten Gillibrand is
apparently a crazy person here she is
saying that now the accusers should not
even go to a sham hearing if they don't
have a hearing it's because they're
trying to silence her and if they do
have a hearing it's because it's a sham
this scenario where it's a he-said
she-said where many members of the
committee have already made up their
minds without the benefit of an FBI
investigation where it's nonpartisan and
objective and without the benefit of
corroborating witnesses being able to
testify it's a sham hearing and I don't
think she should participate in it there
are no corroborating witnesses none zero
mark judge has said that it didn't
happen okay so there's no one who backs
her story there's not a single person
who's in the know who backs her story
they're a bunch of people have nothing
to do who literally know nothing who are
backing her story they're a bunch of
celebrities backing her story so
celebrities I love this they rallied
behind her I remember when they did the
same thing with Juanita Broderick
I remember when Juanita Broderick
accused Bill Clinton of rape and all
these celebrities came forth and they
were like you know what believe Juanita
Broderick I remember five minutes ago
when an accuser came forward and said
they keith ellison beat her up and i
remember when all these same celebrities
cut a video saying believe the woman i
remember when all of these celebrities
cut a video ripping into cory booker for
saying in his actual memoirs that he
grabbed a boob okay there's a quote from
cory booker from his from his memoirs he
wrote in the early 1990s while a student
at stanford okay quote with the top guns
slogan ringing in my head i slowly
reached for her breast after having my
hand pushed away once I reached my mark
and then he said that this was a wake-up
call he said I will never be the same he
wrote in his Stanford a column but where
all the women saying that was a me-too
moment
I remember when all these celebrities
cut a video ripping into Cory Booker how
dare he do that to a woman how dare he
do that to a woman no they didn't do any
of that instead they cut a video about
Brett Kavanaugh what do they know about
Brett Brett Kavanaugh nothing what do
they know about the accuser nothing what
do they know they know that Brett
Kavanaugh is appointed by Trump and from
bad and that means Brett Kavanaugh is
bad and that means Brett Kavanaugh is a
rapist that's basically the logic here
here's a bunch of idiot celebrities who
know as much about this case as my pool
guy sounding off on whether Brett
Kavanaugh is indeed an alleged assault
assault assault or women from all walks
of life are supporting professor
Christine Blasi Ford since coming
forward about Brett I know how difficult
it is to stand up to powerful scape
Julia and more as members of the Senate
determine whether Supreme Court some
waiting for issue is Alyssa Milano
Cavanaugh should serve people you
recognize me he don't know their names
Keisha we are more he confirmed version
maker how he was worried is shared if
ever we applaud your courage in coming
for learning another human would you
tell us they really were credible you
and your testimony you're another human
though the a person with a head medium
we believe you signed your sister's
signed your sisters signed your sisters
ah
signed your sisters we believe you we
who cares you don't know anything about
the case what are you even talking about
okay what like really tell us which
house it happened and then we believe
you signed your sisters it's just it's
astonishing again this has none I love
these protestors showed up in the Senate
yesterday they had lunch cater to them
by the way so somebody was paying for
these protestors to be there here are
the protesters yesterday hundreds of
them showing up at the Capitol building
and chanting we believe women they also
do this outside the Clinton Presidential
Library you've seen it
let me try it trailer in the middle of
Arkansas here's it here's a bunch of
these women
okay
no you know you believe women who say
stuff you want them to say that's that's
the reality of this and we all know it
and we all know it and again the
McCarthyism from the left it's not just
kirsten gillibrand it's amazing Hirono
who's now being proclaimed the champion
of the left by the Washington Post
so the Washington Post which says Maxine
water is a champion to the left they now
say the mazie Hirono is she's senator
from Hawaii she says what does Brett
Kavanaugh have to hide there are at
least 58 communists in the government
right now and I have a list here in my
hand and if you cannot disprove that you
are on this list you are therefore in
the pay of the USSR here we go full
Senator McCarthy from amazing Hirono I'm
counting on the members of the press to
point out that this is a fast track
they are totally intent on getting judge
Cavanaugh on to the Supreme Court come
hell or high water come hell or high
water and you have to ask yourself why
and why isn't judge Cavanaugh asking for
an FBI investigation if he has nothing
to hide y'all should continue just
McCarthyism it's just McCarthyism okay
we'll get to the Republican response in
just one second because the Republicans
suck it pretty much everything we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about your second Amendment right
so you're a gun lover because you feel
like you have the right in the United
States and just as a human being to own
a gun in protection of your family and
in defense of your rights well the u.s.
ECA has a big gun giveaway remember I
told you about it earlier if you want to
win big you have to hurry the US ECA
wants to give you ten free chances to
win the gun of your dreams it is easy
quick and 100% free but it's almost over
this is your last chance because this
ends on Friday when you win you get
1,500 bucks to buy the brand-new gun of
your dreams and remember it's not just
one gun you'll get ten free chances to
win simply text win to the number eight
seven two two two four the official
rules and to instantly lock in your 10
free chances to win it's that easy just
get your phone out right now text win
that's WI n - 8 7 - 2 - this is your
absolute last chance it's too easy way
to value and pass it up again text win -
8 7 - 2 - right now just for doing that
you could win 1500 bucks for doing
something that easy get your 10 free
chances to make your dream come true
right now text win - eight seven - two -
that's win - eight seven - two - the
u.s. CCA has all sorts of great services
educational
says legal defense services they have
all sorts of great stuff go check them
out in any case by texting win to the
number eight seven two two two go check
it out right now because this last
chance ends on Friday so go check it out
all righty so how do Republicans respond
to all this you know hold on before I
get to see how Republicans respond to
all this I just have to point out one
more tweet that just shows the richness
the richness of the hypocrisy of
Democrats on issues relating to women
this one comes courtesy of
representative Joe Kennedy who you may
know from the last name Kennedy and also
from his too thick chapstick during his
response to the State of the Union
address it's a representative Joe
Kennedy the third tweeted out put aside
partisan politics and process kristinb
lazy for deserves to be heard she
deserves decency from our government not
a power play from the GOP Senate yeah
you might want to tell that to your
uncle Ted you might want to tell that to
the guy who left the woman at the bottom
of a river with an air bubble where she
suffocated as he went and got his alibi
ready I don't think that Kennedys should
talk about such things just just me I
think that probably it is not good
optics so how do Republicans respond to
all this here's the thing Kavanagh has
the upper hand right now why because
he's willing to testify because he's
willing to go under oath because he's
not setting conditions on his testimony
because he said no I didn't do it he has
the upper hand because if I come for
with a vague unsubstantiated allegation
and then I refuse to testify under oath
about that allegation and then you say I
didn't do it I'm happy to say that
anywhere anytime under oath I don't care
I'll do it and right now then I'm more
likely to believe you than me right the
person who says they're willing to risk
perjuring themselves to rebut
allegations against them more likely to
trust them so Kavanagh has the upper
hand right now again she's provided no
evidence of time no evidence of place no
evidence of witnesses no evidence of
corroborating people who have said that
they kevin has ever done anything
similar none of that
so Cavanaugh does have the upper hand
and again I repeat the reason I'm taking
this lead the truth case seriously here
is because when somebody makes an
allegation in the series we ought to
treat it seriously it is not being
treated seriously if he did this he's
not gonna be on the Supreme Court nor
should he be if he didn't do it then
this is one of the worst smears I've
ever seen in my entire political life
it's one or
the other there is no in-between so
Republicans have a pretty good case okay
the FBI did what it's supposed to do you
got no evidence we at least have to
question her this guy's willing to
testify under oath it's a pretty good
case for Brett Kavanaugh so instead
Republicans decide to be as stupid as
humanly possible number one they're
going to negotiate to the ends of the
earth to bring forward in give her
everything that she wants they shouldn't
do that they should say listen lady
here's the deal we understand that you
have a story to tell but if you want to
tell that story you actual have to tell
the story we can't just we can't just
accept at face value in allegation with
no substantiating evidence so you're
gonna have to Ashley testify so here's
video we're not going to listen to
demands we're not gonna listen to any of
that we're gonna have a hearing the way
we want to have a hearing because it's
the Senate you to share a committee you
don't get to make demands when the cops
call you in for questioning and you
don't get to make demands when you're a
witness in any criminal trial or in any
civil trial if I recall this a witness
in a civil trial
I couldn't demand to the court what the
lawyers could ask me and what they can't
ask me that's not how it works I think
it to ask me whatever they want so
you're gonna come in and we're going to
allow Brett Kavanaugh or one of his
representatives to question you and
we're going to make you go first and
then Brett Kavanaugh will go second and
then everybody gets heard and then we're
done and if you don't say yes to that
we're calling a vote right now today you
have until this doesn't take you long to
make up in mind you have until a certain
time and at that point we aren't calling
a vote
end of story that's all we're doing
that's it Republicans won't do that
instead Republicans have decided to be
as conciliatory as possible I understand
why right I understand why they're doing
this the reason that they're doing this
obviously is because they don't want to
look like they're sexist and I get that
the problem is there are people like
President Trump so President Trump comes
forward relieved all been we've all been
I think very pleased that President
Trump has stayed as far away from this
as possible because the guy with a bunch
of outstanding sexual you know abuse
allegations probably isn't the guy you
want talking about this on a regular
basis having him in the back room
basically doing whatever he wants to do
play Mario Cart or whatever he does in
his spare time you know all of that is
fine just have him do that
keep away from Twitter don't have him
comment on this if you're Brett
Kavanaugh you're like mr. president stop
just go away right if you're Brett
Kavanaugh so president Trump can't be
kept away from microphones for long he's
it's it's sore
it's sort of like every every movie
where they tie up a monster in the
basement and you know that sooner or
later the monster will break free so
president Trump broke free and he says I
don't think you can delay this hearing
any longer this parts fine what he says
right here to take a man like this and
be spurts now with that being said let
her have her say and let's see how it
all works out but I don't think you can
delay it any longer they've delayed it a
week already
yeah all of that is totally fine then he
gets to the part that's not totally fine
because the Democrats want a narrative
the narrative they want is Republicans
don't care about women Republicans don't
take allegation seriously Republicans
think that women who don't report to the
police are lying so president Trump
decides to jump onto this thing with
both feet because it's a grenade
it is a landmine and as we know the
president has a peculiar propensity like
like a moth to the flame he sees a
political landmine lying there in the
sand he's like you know it'd be fun you
know it'd be a good idea I'm gonna just
jump on that sucker not one foot both so
here he goes saying why didn't she call
the FBI 36 years ago this is a double
whammy of stupid and I will explain why
momentarily why didn't somebody call the
FBI 36 years ago I mean you could also
say when did this all happen what's
going on okay so this is pretty amazing
why is this a double whammy of stupid
one one of the claims people on the
right are making correctly is this is
not within the FBI's jurisdiction it's a
state crime
it happened 36 years ago the other claim
that people on the right are making is
we take her credit we take her
allegation seriously which is why we
would like to see her come forth and
testify Trump in one statement there
dispenses with both of those arguments
he says the FBI should be involved
should have been involved 36 years ago
they should not the implication being
why wouldn't they be involved now right
the follow-up question from the left is
okay you say she should have called the
FBI 36 years ago why don't you just call
the FBI right now so there's that and
then Republicans say we take her
allegation seriously which is why we
want her to say something and Trump says
I don't take her allegation seriously
cuz if she had been serious about them
she would have reported it to the cops
this is silly she was 15 years old there
are a lot of reasons why women don't go
to the police and law enforcement in
cases of sexual assault or abuse often
they
you'll embarrassed often they feel
ashamed often they start to blame
themselves there are lots of
psychological studies on this just
because a 15 year old girl didn't go to
the cops in 1982 doesn't mean that
nothing happened to her in 1982 we have
too many cases of people being abused
and then it comes out that they actually
were abused and they didn't report it
until much later because they
internalized the abuse that sort of
stuff happens fairly regularly not just
in the United States but around the
world
so president from jumping on that
grenade up and then he decides you know
what I'm gonna double down on this
because it was so smart when I said it
last night with Shaun I'm gonna say this
on Twitter this morning so he tweets out
I have no doubt that if the attack on
dr. Ford was as bad as she says charges
would have been immediately filed with
local law enforcement authorities that
either her or her loving parents I asked
that you bring those pilings forward so
that we can learn date time and place
well again she didn't have to file
charges for nothing to be true and this
makes it look like you're not taking the
allegation seriously which is all
Democrats really want out of this anyway
Democrats all they want is to call
Republican sexist so thanks for that mr.
president that's that's super helpful
then he tweets out they follow up and
his follow up is the radical left
lawyers now want the FBI to get involved
why didn't someone call the FBI 36 years
ago again same pointee made with with
Sean just not a good point that wasn't
the limit of Republican stupidity
yesterday so Ed Whelan I mentioned him
yesterday on the show I was shocked by
this Ed Whelan writes for National
Review he's the head of the ethics and
Public Policy Center he's about as I
would say considered a fellow as I have
ever seen in American public life he's
somebody who meticulously writes bench
memos which is a meticulously written
blog for National Review about like
specific paragraphs in specific court
decisions he's somebody who really puts
his ducks in a row before he says
anything and he had suggested yesterday
there will be evidence coming out that
will exonerate Brett Kavanaugh and I
said we don't know what that is yet but
coming from Ed Whelan we have to take
that seriously it turns out that Ed
Whelan was just basically speculating
rank speculation he puts out a tweet
thread yesterday there is no excuse for
this and it's idiotic he puts out a
tweet thread yesterday suggesting that
like complete with Zillow maps and home
charts of a house near a place
where he says that the physical
description of the home matches the
physical description that Blasi Ford put
forth and then he puts a picture online
of a classmate of Brett Cavanaugh's from
high school who looks kind of like Brett
Kavanaugh and he suggests basically that
this guy is Brett Cavanaugh's evil twin
and so Ford has mixed up this guy and
Brett Kavanaugh it's a pretty solid case
for defamation okay that guy could
easily sue ed Whelan and maybe and maybe
win some significant dollars Whelan
later deleted the entire tweet thread
and said oh that was a mistake I shoulda
done that why would you put that out
again the burden of proof is on the
accuser she's provided no proof and
won't testify as of right now why would
you do that Ed Whelan idiotic now my
guess is that he thinks Cavanaugh is
innocent and he's just going to whatever
length and then he sort of convinced
himself this is a good idea but whatever
it is there's no excuse for it obviously
and that's why you had to back off of it
Oh Republicans how often you disappoint
me all you had to do here was simply
maintain that you're going to have her
testify and then try to have her provide
some additional information or evidence
and when she doesn't you say we're
holding the vote end of story we're done
that's it not difficult yet somehow
somehow they managed to seize at least
some defeat out of the jaws of victory
all righty before we go any further and
we'll talk about the media treatment of
all this plus we have to get to the
mailbag before we go any further let's
talk about managing your money
betterment it's the smart way to manage
your money better mint is how you
outsmart average it's the investing tool
for people who refuse to settle for
average investing what is betterment do
for you well it's a technology designed
to help you make more from your
investments it's a limited expert advice
designed to help you make smart
financial decisions I have an financial
advisor you can have a financial advisor
as well and that's basically what
betterment is they give you tax
efficient investing strategies that give
you an edge low transparent fees
constant access to information and tools
that allow you to track progress toward
your goals you can always feel like a
smart savvy investor they are your
online financial advisor and listen I
don't have time to manage my own money
and I need the best advice I can get you
do too everyone does because you have a
job right so go check them out right now
betterment outsmart average investing
does involve risk but ben shapiro show
listeners can get up to one year managed
for free for more information visit
betterment comm slash shapiro
that's beat
de RM ENT comm / apparel betterment comm
/ shapiro betterment is how you outsmart
average go check them out right now
betterment comm / repair to get up to
one year manage for free alright so the
media treatment of this situation
continues to be absolutely abhorrent
there have been a bevy of columns that
have come out recently saying they don't
care whether Cavanaugh is guilty or
innocent he deserves to be tried and
convicted in the court of public opinion
because he's a man and men are Evo men
are bad and therefore because all men
are bad and Brett Kavanaugh is a man
then by the by the Greek logic this
means that Brett Kavanaugh raped a girl
or tried to rape a girl in 1982 and they
put out a story from the Washington Post
yesterday that his frat house in college
was walking around campus with a flag
made out of women's panties so I'm I
failed to see the connection
so if frat house did what frat houses do
and that means he must have attempted to
rape a girl in 1982 got it that makes
perfect sense to me makes perfect sense
and then there's Chris Cuomo who
continues to try to outshine his brother
on CNN he had an argument with Kellyanne
Conway and all of these all of these
interviews with Kelly on comma between
Cuomo and Conway are basically just
Cuomo shouting at her that you should
shut up and kind of way shouting at him
that she doesn't want to shut up and
that's what this turned into you want to
lay the blame at somebody's feet look no
further than your Democratic friends
starting with senator Feinstein even the
Democrats are angry with her if dr. Ford
isn't anybody just hate critics critics
that's Mitch McConnell say many times
you're always welcome to come on but I
didn't say nothing came out of my mouth
yet you're just a lot of noise coming
for nothing coming out of your mouth I
believe I can leave and we can watch and
get confirmed next week you ready for
that and good for Kellyanne Conway
because that's exactly what Republicans
should do at this point okay if the
accuser won't come forward if Democrats
continue to Stonewall just to throw a
cloud over a guy who they have no idea
whether he actually did any of this
stuff then they should just cut this out
and they should and they should have the
vote and confirm them enough is enough
okay well we are going to get into the
mail
back in just a second first you have to
go over to daily wire to subscribe any
part of the mailbag by the way for $9.99
a month get the rest of the show live
the rest of Andrew Clavin show live the
rest of Michael Knowles is show live if
that's the thing you are into the rest
of Matt Walsh has shown as well we do
have a Matt Walsh podcast that you
should check out go check out all of
those things for $9.99 a month Plus this
the very greatest you know beverage
vessels the $99 a year version you get
this the leftist year's hot or cold mug
tumblr tumblr I know and go check that
out because it is spectacular and is a
better deal than the monthly also when
you subscribe to YouTube or iTunes that
means you get access to our Sunday
special which features the inimitable
Glenn Beck this week we have a bunch of
great guests coming up in the next few
weeks I mean really awesome guests
you're going to want to be a part of it
go check it out at youtube or itunes
right now we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so let's mailbag it up it's
time to mailbag it up so John says long
live overlord Shapiro I know you don't
necessarily advocate owning the libs
just to do it but today would you please
entertain us with the most triggering
thing you have ever said to a leftist at
anytime anywhere and the most triggered
reaction you got Zoe turn on CNN
Headline News doesn't count
well obviously being physically
assaulted on a national news network
probably would be the best example which
is what happened with zoe tur when zoe
turner suggested that i didn't know
anything about biology little boy and
kept saying that over and over and so he
turned as a transgender woman and i said
what are your genetic sir and then he
grabbed me by the back of the neck on
national TV and threatened to send me
home in an ambulance which as always
makes no sense you know go home in an
ambulance that was that was it but I'm
trying to think what I've said it's the
most triggering well they're a bunch of
situations where people have gotten very
upset at me obviously the one that comes
to mind is actually one that was not
like a public event so I was in a Habad
house in at Harvard he's a Friday night
and at Harvard everybody is on the left
and on Friday nights you go to the
Chabad House for the Friday night dinner
and this girl comes in with her
boyfriend
and she's sitting across from me and she
wants to talk politics and I was like
okay fine so she starts talking politics
and she's talking about the mandatory
maximum workweek in France and she says
what we should do here in the United
States is we should have a maximum
workweek meaning like 40 hours a week or
35 hours a week that should be the
maximum and then you shouldn't be
allowed to work anymore and I said
that's a really dumb idea here's all the
reasons why that's a really dumb idea
and she kept just saying that it was the
most compassionate thing to do and at a
certain point I said listen you really
don't know a lot about this topic and if
you're this ignorant about this topic
I assume you're I mean you brought it up
I assume you're this ignorant about
other topics as well and so I really
would prefer that you not vote like
please don't vote because you don't know
what it is you're talking about your
vote counts the same as my vote so don't
vote and her boyfriend was sitting next
to her and her boyfriend starts nodding
because her boyfriend realizes that I'm
right and she gets very upset and you
can see her starting to well up and at
this point I feel bad and she goes
downstairs and he goes downstairs at
this Chabad house and I can hear them
yelling at each other and then they come
back upstairs she sits back down
across from me and she wants to talk
politics some more and I was like no
we're done we're like once I make you
cry we're finished here there's nothing
more for me to do like I can I can't
have a conversation I said I actually
said to her it considered this the
limousine I'm the driver that the window
just went up there is no more talking we
are finished here this is so that was
probably that's the one that comes to
mind anyway okay Bryan says to the
Hayley Shapiro 2024 campaign this
morning there is news about three
different workplace shootings across
America in the last 24 hours
two of them seem fairly normal though I
find it horrifying there's a normal
among such evil acts
the third however was regarding a
transgender individual pronouns and
biological gender not given in the
article is not about the victims of the
person shooting but about the person's
hard life personal struggles and the
poetry on their blog site as well as
many commendations from his or her peers
about the character and good will of the
shooter is this what the nation is
turning to not only are minority groups
the victims of the most horrible country
that has ever existed but now when they
commit crimes they're the victims Brian
well I mean obviously this has been a
tendency on the part of the left is to
attribute crime when it is not a member
of a majority group to the sins of the
society at large this is something left
really really likes to do they will say
that higher crime rates in certain areas
that's a result of victimization at the
top level they say this about terrorism
abroad by the way after 9/11 who was
left saying why why do they hate us as
though we had somehow provoked their
hatred and that's why they had taken
down two of our towers and the Pentagon
the left has a tendency always to blame
America for the problems of individual
decision making and that's a serious a
serious issue and it does you know it is
fascinating to watch as they apply to
some folks but but not to others Allen
says heibon how do i best explain to my
sixteen-year-old son the difference is
between Democrats Republicans liberals
and conservatives love your show
give soccer a chance Allen so the truth
is I don't hate soccer as much as I say
I hate soccer it's more of just a
cultural stereotype me hating soccer
I've actually been to a soccer match in
Seattle I was taking about my friend
Jason Rance and it was amusing it was
amusing I will say the enthusiasm at
soccer match is pretty high so I don't
hate soccer as much as I proclaim to and
what are the differences between
Democrats and Republicans well the
difference is between Democrats and
Republicans are really less relevant
than the difference between liberals and
conservatives I would say that the
differences between liberals and
conservatives come down to a couple of
things one people on the Left tend to
believe that
nature is inherently good and therefore
if you just release people from the
shackles of judeo-christian values then
they will live better lives and then if
we use reason and the collective then we
can create a better utopian society that
sort of the vision of the left and
collective rights Trump individual
rights individuals are not as important
as the greatest good for the greatest
number crammed down by a government made
up of the best right that's sort of the
the leftist ideal they also value
equality of outcome over equality of
opportunity life is unfair which means
that if unfair stuff happens then that
is the responsibility of the government
to rectify
people on the right tend to think if
something unfair happened maybe there's
no way to prevent that all we can do is
ensure that you have the same rights as
everybody else
and that would be I can think the
central different again the right
believes in in it unalienable god-given
rights to the individual that government
cannot trample the left believes that
rights are created by the collective
they are created by governments and
therefore it can be taken away by
government in the interests of the
collective though Stephen says hi Ben do
you think we should end the Fed or does
it serve a legitimate purpose thanks and
have a great weekend kind of torn on it
to be honest with you I'm not a big fan
of the Federal Reserve I think that the
Federal Reserve is is unnecessary to a
certain extent and the Federal Reserve
provides a couple of functions it lends
out to to various banks it ensures that
those banks have backing in case those
banks should go down this is why your
personal deposits are guaranteed by the
Federal Reserve I think that the the
Federal Reserve is I'm not a big fan I'm
not a big fan josh says hey Ben as a
fellow comic book fan I wanted to know
if you've watched daredevil on Netflix
and if so what you think of it thanks
the big problem with daredevil on
Netflix is that daredevil is the least
interesting character on daredevil that
is the problem with daredevil so all the
other characters are much more
interesting so the second season which
had the Punisher in it the Punisher was
a much better character than daredevil
and daredevil loses every arguments of
the Punisher they hate they keep having
arguments where Darren was like you
can't kill that guy why would you kill
that guy and Punisher is like cuz if I
don't kill that guy he's gonna come back
and kill somebody and third it was like
that's mean and the Punisher says well
right cuz he's bad guy and then we're
supposed to agree with daredevil which
doesn't make any sense at all it's
really stupid
daredevil is less interesting than
kingpin in the first season the problem
with daredevil is that they make him
kind of like a pansy who does an inch
jumps and that's and that's really
that's that's really irritating so and I
was a big fan of the daredevil comics
when I was growing up Alec says you're
obviously a fan of good classical music
have you ever been interested in choral
music I believe it can be even more
moving than orchestral music yeah I do
like choral music Brahms is German
Requiem is is really pretty spectacular
the obviously the Bach mass is is
spectacular stuff I love opera the in
Fidelio the prisoners chorus is a choral
number obviously yeah there's some
there's some really terrific choral
music justice has does Trump run again
for 2020 if so do you think the media
and Facebook Twitter shut down and
conservatives will stop a read win he
does run again in 2020 because he
nothing will stop him and he's the
president I'm why shouldn't they do I
think that Facebook and media crackdown
will hurt him yeah because that's what
it's designed knew I mean the social
media have decided that they are not
going to allow free discourse of ideas
particularly if it helps president Trump
there's a story from Daily Caller today
and Tucker Carlson reported it as well
all about how there is a Google full-on
discussion of how to skew search results
to hurt President Trump
it seems to me evidence that the social
media companies are very much to the
left and they are insulted the Trump is
president Blake says since I'm coming to
LA for the first time for politican is
there anything in particular you should
think and think I should see or do well
a lot of my daily water colleagues are
gonna be at poetic on I'll be doing a
big Q&A and then I'm also on a panel
later I believe is that right I don't
know and something like that and then
Elisha Kraus will be there
Andrew Clavin will be there I would
recommend you see all of those and then
Michael moles will be there also and you
asked me what you should or should not
do so Claire says hi Ben I have a
question about the national debt in the
US I understand the textbook reason why
managing our debt is important however
when I look around and see all the
economic stability and growth we are
currently experiencing I can understand
why people do not take our national debt
seriously can you explain why managing
our national debt is important and
perhaps give a few examples of countries
who have not taken their debt seriously
Thank You Claire sure Venezuela didn't
take its national debt seriously and
thus when they went to pay back their
national debt they had no money and no
one could sell additional bonds they had
to keep government spending
that mean they had to inflate their
currency this is what happens right by
Marr Germany same sort of thing if you
don't pay back your national debt at a
certain point people lose faith in your
debt because all of these monetary items
are no longer backed by gold so it's not
like you can walk into a bank plop down
a dollar and get the dollars worth of
gold
instead it is backed by The Full Faith
and Credit of the United States well
that means that basically you trust the
US is going to pay off its debts what
happens if the debt reaches an
unsustainable point where it doesn't
look like the US is ever going to pay
off its debts at that point it's
impossible to sell additional bonds
which is what funds current government
spending at that point you either have
to take austerity measures meaning
cutting Social Services or you have to
inflate the currency or both and and
that's when the economy goes to hell in
a handbasket and when you get social
unrest because people feel that they're
owed certain things they've been
promised and they don't get those things
that's what you saw in Greece you've
seen it in Spain
you're starting to see it in some of the
Nordic countries where they're cutting
back Social Services or restructuring
some of the Social Services the only
reason they haven't been doing it in
countries like Norway is because they
have an enormous oil slush one
let's see Joe says hi Ben with
everything regarding Brett Kavanaugh do
you think men and women with good
character and morality will now be less
likely to enter the fields of politics
in addition with tribalism getting out
of hand does this make you hesitant to
consider a possible run into American
politics thanks and love the show
absolutely absolutely if you're a good
person and you're somebody who takes
criticism to heart you don't want to be
anywhere near politics when I was a kid
I thought a lot about being on the
Supreme Court in fact if you watched the
tape of me at the Israeli bonds banquet
when I'm 11 years old 12 years old Larry
King leads off by saying that I want to
be the first Orthodox Jew on the Supreme
Court so I've been into politics since
as long as I can remember what I
actually want to be in government at any
point here I don't think so because the
viciousness of people who take
everything that you ever did out of
context in order to destroy you is
astonishing they paid a number of people
who are willing to make things up to
destroy you is incredible would you want
to go through that really I don't know
it's I think what you're gonna get is
the people who have the least capacity
for shame running in politics and that
also happens to be generally the worst
people people who have no capacity for
shame are people who are willing to do
anything people who are willing to do
anything should not be in charge of the
levers of the nation's government but
that's exactly what you're gonna get
thanks to the targeted Search and
Destroy mission of the media and the
tribal politics in which we exist Travel
says Ben
if enough of your supporters agreed to
raise the money you would need to be
Trump's personal twitter advisor and
counselor what would that number be and
would you please consider taking the
position think about it well number one
I don't think that you can actually be
paid and I don't know how that would
work
number two it wouldn't work it's like
being Trump's lawyer then you think
there aren't people in the White House
who look at from Suites and go dude just
stop I'm sure that every day somebody
says to mr. president do you think
that's well advised because yes I love
it tweeted nine times
he does what he won't say too he's the
president's in the United States he
can't shut down his Twitter account his
advice he doesn't listen to his advisers
on this kind of stuff if he did he would
have stopped it a long time ago believe
me I know yeah and I talked to people in
the White House this is not like it's
not that people in the White House don't
know what's going on with his Twitter
account is that they have given up it's
basically his Twitter account is Dante's
seventh circle of hell abandon hope all
ye who enter here if you go into the
White House you know he's gonna tweet
that's just the way this is gonna work
let's see V says how do you fit your
life into 24 hours
it seems to me between your job your
wife or your kids your religious
obligations your watercolors indeed
Skillshare calm and watching all the TV
and reading all the books you talk about
I'm assuming you eat and sleep at some
point as well you run out of time
similar what's the secret the secret is
you really have to segment your time you
really there's no such thing as
multitasking multitasking means MF you
basically have to sit and you have to
say okay now for the next two hours I'm
writing now for the next hour I'm doing
my show now for the next hour and go
work out and then after that I'm gonna
learn a little Talmud and then after
that I'm going to go it I'm gonna write
some more and then after that I'm gonna
go and pick up my daughter at school
you really have to segment your time you
have to organize your time in a real way
that means you have to sit down before
the day begins and say here are the
tasks I have to do here's the amount of
time I'll allotting to each task and
here's how I'm going to do it at a
certain point it sort of becomes rote at
a certain point you don't have to write
it down anymore you just get used to
doing it in your own head so today for
example yeah I have to I know that I'm
gonna have to get up in the morning I'm
gonna have to write a couple of pieces I
need to get it done early so I have time
later this afternoon to pre-plan the Fox
show that I'm doing on Sunday right all
of this is is just a planning process
that you have to go through I know that
later today I have a couple of
interviews on Fox like I know what my
schedule is going to be I used to be
much worse at this also you have to say
no to things this is the biggest thing
honestly I'm a person who says yes
pretty much everything people want part
of your time they want you to talk they
want you to email they want you to talk
on the phone and hang out with them you
really have to decide whether it's worth
it and when somebody says listen I just
want five minutes of your time there is
no such thing as just five minutes of
your time it doesn't work that way
because it takes you 10 minutes to
extricate yourself from what you're
doing here spend the five minutes and
then 15 minutes to get back into what
you were doing every five minutes of
your time is actually 25 minutes of your
time maybe more maybe 30 so that means
that if somebody asks there's a great
article about this and I can't remember
who wrote it I wish I wish I did so I
could give credit but when I read it I
was like this is exactly right when
somebody walks in and then interrupts me
in the middle of a thought process and
like I just need a second that second
just cost me 10 minutes because mentally
you have to get into a place where you
are focused in where you're in the
middle of what psychologically they call
flow where you're just ensconced in the
process and really engage if you don't
if you're not in that flow then you are
not gonna be able to get a lot of things
done so you really have to block
yourself off turn off the TV don't have
distractions available to you and just
sit and concentrate Ryan okay final
question here hey Ben not gonna lie to
you it truly broke my heart when I
learned you are a Celtics fan I'm a
Lakers fan but please don't terminate my
subscription what has been your favorite
moment in the Lakers celtics rivalry
well all of my favorite moments from
Laker Celtics rivalry actually happened
like in my deep deep youth so I would
have to say that the 1980 the 1984
finals were really satisfying as a
Celtics fan the Celtics won in seven the
1986 finals were great for the Celtics
but the Lakers weren't there they were
defeated by the Houston Rockets on the
way there most of the great Pennell
acres Celtics rivalry stuff happened
really
before I was sentient right when I when
I was very very young because by the
time the Lakers and Celtics were both
good again like 2009-2010 they didn't
meet in the finals except when the
Lakers won so that was terrible and
awful and horrible that was the worst so
I hated that so then so there's that
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things I
like there is a book called coddling of
the American mind by Greg Wilkie on/off
and Jonathan hight Jonathan hight is
going to come on the Sunday special at
some point in the very near future I
believe what two weeks a week and a half
something like that so Jonathan height
is just one of my favorite social
psychologists he teaches at NYU his book
the righteous mind is terrific I've
recommended it on the show before he has
a book all the happiness hypothesis is
also terrific I've recommended it on the
show before I believe the coddling of
the American mind is his latest book
with Greg lukianov it's all about how
good intentions and bad ideas are
setting up a generation for failure
it's about microaggressions identity
politics all the things I like to talk
about backed with all sorts of hard data
I really like it a lot particularly
because it repeats a lot of the
arguments that I've quoted Hite making
on the show and in my speeches before so
if you really want a primer on what's
happening on college campuses and why we
are creating a generation of weak-minded
people go check it out the coddling of
the American mind how good intentions
and bad ideas are setting up a
generation for failure by Greg lukianov
and Jonathan Hite okay things I hate
today's thing I hate comes courtesy of
the New York Times host nikki Haley was
on with martha maccallum yesterday and
she summed up the fact that the New York
Times had essentially slandered her by
saying that she was responsible for
buying these very very very very
expensive curtains when it turns out she
was not in fact responsible for buying
those deeply expensive curtains they
were actually commissioned by the Obama
administration in the hopes that they
would be occupied by Democrat she tells
her story last night on Fox News she you
talked to the New York Times and said
this isn't the case and they printed it
anyway they printed it anyway and it was
down in the story and like the seventh
paragraph down at the bottom and then
they had to post a retraction so that's
twice but we shouldn't you know all last
weekend everyday wherever I went people
were asking me about my curtains the
damage is done once the story is out I
appreciate the retraction but that story
follows you everywhere you go but that
is that's the tough part about public
life yeah and of course nikki Haley is
exactly correct and it's it's really the
reason why good minded good-hearted
people don't want to go into politics
lately
would you want to they literally just
make things up about you and then oops
sorry my bad it's really dangerous and
we're not immune to it on the right side
of the aisle either it's just it's such
a tribal environment that you really
have to work to get past your cognitive
biases okay other things that I hate
this is
just awful wealthy Elliott is from the
Atlantic wealthy La Schools vaccination
rates are as low as South Sudan's
Hollywood parents not vaccinating they
say it makes instinctive sense now their
kids have whooping cough because they're
idiots because they're idiots
vaccinations work they're one of the
great scientific developments in the
history of humankind all you have to do
is look at the statistics I've written
about this extensively go to daily wire
search Shapiro vaccination rates I
talked about how when vaccination rates
hit 100 disease rates in many cases hit
zero there's also such a thing as herd
immunity it matters whether you
vaccinate your kid because if you do not
vaccinate your kid my kid could get sick
even if my kid has had a vaccine for
example whooping cough perfect example
my daughter had whooping cough
she was vaccinated the reason she had
whooping cough is because the whooping
cough vaccine is only about 80%
effective
well the 100 percent of the population
has the vaccine and it's 80% effective
then it is much more likely that she is
not going to come into contact with
someone with whooping cough than if no
one has the vaccine and she takes it
vaccine that is 80% effective this is
just obvious math but there bunch of
people out there who say well you know I
don't feel like vaccinating because my
kid's gonna get autism there is no
scientific data suggest that none okay
there's a really bad study for which a
guy was basically disbarred in the UK
there's one horrible scientific study I
based on this there's nothing else the
problems with vaccines are their
occasional problems with vaccines like
ganbare syndrome yes okay that that has
happened that has been a thing in the
past
is it a my new number of people
absolutely and not only that they have
been consistently trying to make
vaccines better to minimize the risk if
you're not vaccinating your kid you're
being a okay really I this is my I
really believe this in a very strong way
I think it is absolutely foolish and it
has externalities because there are
pregnant women who can't get vaccines
and if they get sick he goes to the baby
there are people that are kids with
leukemia who can't get a vaccine and you
not vaccinating your kid and making your
kid a carrier for that disease can hurt
the kid with leukemia there are
externalities to you not getting a
vaccine if it were just about you and
your kid not getting a vaccine first of
all I would say don't endanger your own
kid because it's silly but second I
might say okay at least it is an
autonomy issue once it becomes an
externality once you become a carrier of
a disease that affects my kid now we're
talking about something completely
different the Holi
reporter has a great investigation for
what should sought the vaccination
records of elementary schools all over
LA County
they found vaccination rates in elite
neighborhoods like Santa Monica and
Beverly Hills have tanked and the
incidence of whooping cough there has
skyrocketed
shocker yes vaccinations work and it is
amazing the privilege that wealth
affords you to be a is amazing the
reason that people in South Sudan don't
have vaccines is because it's incredibly
poor and no one has access to vaccine
the reason people in Beverly Hills don't
have vaccines is because they're idiots
who believe in essential oils really who
think that that herbal remedies are
going to are going to fix their Luka are
gonna fix their whooping cough yeah go
down and try and get some of that st.
John's wort and see if it's gonna fix
your broken leg again I'm not against
organic herbal remedies for what they're
good for but let's not pretend that this
stuff is a substitute for actual tested
and verified medicine ridiculous
ridiculous all right we'll be back here
on Monday with well actually we won't
actually I have another Jewish holiday
so I won't tough deal with it I'll be
back here on Wednesday with the latest
at that point make sure that you tune in
on Sunday to our Fox News special right
we have the Ben Shapiro election special
happening 8:00 p.m. on Sunday go check
that out don't worry folks I'm not
violating my own holiday it's filmed
before the actual holiday right because
it's only 5:00 p.m. on the on Sunday on
the on the west coast go check it out
I hope that you love it I hope I do well
I mean I hope that it doesn't suck so
you'll find out on Sunday soon enough
and then leave me or if you I won't be
able to the good news is I don't even
know if I suck until after the holiday
and I'll check Tuesday night by then the
world will have moved on Brett Kavanaugh
will set himself on fire or something
like that that's that's where we'll be
but in any case I'll be back here on
Wednesday to recap all of it I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018